today on the matt walsh show as we head
into another school year with our kids
subjected to mask mandates and on top of
the usual leftist indoctrination they'll
experience we need to ask one question
is it possible to save the school system
or is it time to simply abandon it talk
about that also cnn starts firing
employees who don't get the vaccine and
a gallup poll finds that uh basically no
hispanic person actually wants to be
called latinx big shocker there and a
journalist fires a so-called
quote-unquote assault rifle for the
first time and his reaction is hilarious
plus the metal-winning women's olympic
weightlifters are asked about the the
male who competed against them and their
response tells you everything you need
to know although at the same time it
tells you nothing and our daily
cancellation will have the story of a
hollywood actress who says she is
expressing her love and devotion for her
husband by divorcing him all of that and
more today on the matt walsh show
you know if you have people who rely on
you which uh which i'm sure you do i
know i certainly do it's it is could
never be more important to get life
insurance that is uh really a
responsibility you have
to the people who rely on you
it's i think it's a moral duty on top of
just a practical necessity as well and
that's where policy genius comes in
policy genius makes it easy to compare
quotes from over a top from over a dozen
top insurers all in one place
why should you compare well you could
save 50 or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius you
could save 1300 more per year on life
insurance by using policy genius to
compare policies that is that's savings
that i think almost no one short of like
multi-millionaires can afford to give up
the license expert at policy genius
works for you not for the insurance
company so you can trust them to help
you navigate every step of the shopping
and buying process and that's a really
important thing as well getting started
is easy first head to policygenius.com
in minutes you can work out how much
life insurance coverage you need and you
can compare personalized quotes to find
your best price and then you just choose
the one you want and policy genius
handles all the paperwork it's as simple
as that so head to policygenius.com to
get started right now policy genius when
it comes to insurance it's nice to get
it right
the clark county school district one of
the largest in the country has just
unveiled a new equitable grading policy
it's the kind of policy that i would
have loved when i was in school which is
about the harshest condemnation
imaginable
the new system removes non-academic
measures as factors in grading so those
measures include attendance
participation responsibility lateness
none of that matters anymore in terms of
the grades students
no longer need to worry that their grade
in a class will suffer just because they
aren't actually going to the class
attendance was you know considered a
bare minimum requirement when i went to
school
now it has become a mere superficial
detail also all scores under 50 percent
are abolished
um a child cannot get less than 50 on an
assignment even if they don't actually
do it don't do it at all and they spot
you 50 percent
the word failing has been removed from
the school's vocabulary now students
earning a score you know between 50 and
59
will be classified as emergent
once again i wish i had thought of this
as a kid no dad i'm not failing math i'm
uh i'm emerging
the superintendent of the district jesus
jarrah recently defended the new policy
saying that quote our kids will graduate
from this high school ready for the
workforce in high paying jobs
yes you know those high high-paying jobs
where you don't need to show up or do
anything or put in the slightest effort
or actually succeed in any of the tasks
you're assigned
well at least we can hope that these
students upon entering the job market
will be fired with similarly gentle
language listen i'm not firing you i'm
just saying your ass needs to emerge
through the exit and never come back
that's all
this is of course far from the only
equitable quote unquote grading policy
to be unveiled in the last couple of
years it's the direction that all school
districts will will eventually go
all of them
of course attending class is kind of a
moot point anyway if there is no class
to physically attend in the first place
though indeed biden's secretary of
education gave a press conference
yesterday where he was very open to the
idea of shutting down in-person learning
once again this year let's uh listen to
that
is there anything metrics wise or
numbers-wise threshold-wise that you
would look at and say all right maybe in
person is not the best
answer right now even if the year gets
started or is it in person no matter
what we have the mitigation tools you
know
we know what works
and
yes we're looking at the metrics and
obviously in close consultation with cdc
and local health directors because there
are many local factors that contribute
to whether or not a school should be
open
now that was just a longer way of saying
yes we will definitely be shutting the
schools down at some point at least
partially that's how i read it that
would be my prediction anyway
and it's probably for the best actually
because as kids across the country
are if they go to school going to be
forced to wear masks all day in their
classes
every day another school district and
states a mass mandate most recently in
fact our district right here in
nashville has been added to the list all
students and staff will be required to
wear masks all day everywhere from the
bus to the classroom
now as always with these mask mandates
the one thing that's missing is any sort
of
rational science and common sense based
reason for it
instead we hear only from the adults
that it makes them feel better and that
it seems like it's necessary to keep the
kids safe
though they offer absolutely no data to
support it at all
just to um illustrate that point here's
a quick news report from our local abc
affiliate here in town and just listen
to this and you tell me do you hear
anything like
you know a data point
a reason
let's let's listen and find out
i feel a lot better sending my kid into
school and i think you know there are a
lot of parents feeling that same way
right now there were some opposing
parents but i think there were a lot
more supportive parents and i was very
happy to see that right now my son can't
get vaccinated but he does have to go to
school so i want to do everything i can
to keep him safe in that in that context
city is open
city-wide no citywide mandate there is
no data to support any of this right now
there is not no state mandate mass
mandate so why are we doing this to our
children and our job is to make sure
that we are protecting our students we
cannot teach them if we cannot protect
them
and so i would like us to continue to
follow with the proven mitigation
strategies that are
available to us
masks will be available on a daily basis
for anyone who forgets to bring theirs
to school the board will reassess this
mask requirement when all metro
government issued mass grant
requirements are ended
well there was at least it was an eight
to one vote on the school board and you
heard from the one sane one i think her
name was fran bush and she was the she
was the only one
who was against it the rest of it though
what did you hear i feel a lot better
but you know i feel better
we want to keep the kids safe
lots of feels and wants here as as usual
but is the mask necessary in order to
keep kids safe from covid
a virus which poses very little risk to
them to begin with
is it psychologically and physically
healthy to have children wearing these
pieces of cloth on their faces all day
how many of the kids even wear them
correctly
how dirty do these things get by the end
of the day
what effect does that have on their
health
do the health benefits actually outweigh
the risks these are all questions and by
the way
what does it do to children
emotionally and developmentally to
deprive them of the basic ability to see
each other's faces
what does it do to children emotionally
and developmentally and psychologically
to make them feel like speaking of feels
make them feel like everyone around them
is sick
that the air itself is toxic
has anybody wondered about any of that
is there any data on it
do they care about the data if it does
exist
the answer to that question at least the
last question is no the point is simply
that the adults in charge feel better
when the kids cover their faces all day
and that's what matters most to them
now of course
we can protest these kinds of measures
and we should we can object
just as we can object to the insane
equitable grading policies or to crt in
the schools or the gender theory
indoctrination or any of the other
radical left-wing indoctrination
that that public school children endure
in every public school in america
without exception we can object
we should object we can protest we
should we should protest
but we're left still at bottom with a
stark reality
that when we send our kids into the
system
we have no actual control over anything
that happens
no actual control no hands-on control
the schools own your kids as long as
they are in that building and even when
they're not in the building
that anyway is how the schools see it
and they don't hide the fact
and for all intents and purposes they're
right
the system has your child for most of
his waking hours the system is in charge
of educating him and thus shaping his
worldview and instilling him with a
moral code things which are inextricably
linked to the act of education that's
another important point
people that say well we need to separate
indoctrination and education i just want
my kids to be educated i don't want them
to be indoctrinated that's impossible
the two are linked you cannot have
education without indoctrination
unless you're educating a computer
unless you're programming a computer
but when it comes to human to human
education
it is it always comes packaged with a
world view always
no it's not that i don't want my kid to
be indoctrinated
i don't want to me i don't want him to
be indoctrinated by them
i don't want him to be indoctrinated
into that
and what happens is that the system
eventually will have more influence over
your kids than you do
your kid will become what the system
makes him
there may be
rare exceptions to that rule but they
are very rare indeed
all of these things we're witnessing
right now from the masking to the
indoctrination and everything in between
is the system exercising its ownership
of the children sent into its care
the mask becomes in some ways the most
profound statement of ownership almost
like branding on cattle
and that probably is the best analogy
because that's how kids in the system
are treated they're like farm animals to
be conformed into a herd and then herded
along in whatever direction it prefers
if your kid goes to public school
then i mean it's good to get involved as
much as possible and to show up at the
school board meetings and to join the
pta and do all that you can do but this
cannot be the ultimate solution to the
problem of the public school system
because these are band-aid measures
this is you with a bucket on the beach
struggling against the tide
you can't stop it you can only hope to
interfere slightly
interfering slightly is better than not
at all
but it's not a solution
so what is the solution what's the
answer
the answer is the one i always give but
not everybody wants to hear it
the solution to the public school system
in the end is its abandonment
and then its collapse and its
destruction
that's the solution
as long as we are determined to
outsource our children's formation to
the state
as long as we have given it that immense
power
these problems will remain
there is never
going to be a time
when you can actually trust the state to
educate your child
never
it is too much power
it is too much power for any government
at any time
but especially this government at this
time
if we can improve anything at all in the
system
it's only by degree
you can hope by getting involved to make
it slightly less bad
but
anything more than that will require
fundamental and drastic change
you know people
say to me all the time
um well matt you you point out all these
problems
and what are the solutions
you don't give us any solutions we want
solutions
well my answer to that is number one
there is value in pointing out the
problem when much of the country doesn't
see the problem so we got to start with
that you know you got to drag the
darkness into the light
you got to start there
and in some ways we haven't been able to
get past that as a culture yet
we can't work to fix a problem until
everyone sees that it is one and so
right now we're at square one
just getting people to see that the
problem exists
but the other thing with solutions is
that when most people when they say i
don't want to hear all these problems i
want to hear solutions
they don't really want solutions do they
when they say solutions they mean okay
give me a five step plan that's easy to
do
and will require almost no sacrifice on
my part
that's what i want
you know tell me to write a letter to
these people tell me to hold a sign over
here tell me to do this to do that and
then the problem will go away
you know we are way past that there
aren't any
all of the serious problems in our
culture out of all of them none of them
can be simply solved that way
it requires drastic changes so when it
comes to the school system if you really
want to know the solution
it is to abandon it
it is to starve it to death
by pulling your kids out of it
but we can't do that
we have to drastically change our
lifestyle
we we have to change everything yeah i
know
it's not easy
but it's the solution there isn't
another one
it's the only one
now we have to decide do we really want
to solve the problem or not
now let's get to our five headlines
you know i don't know if i have
mentioned this yet but ben shapiro has a
new book out just came out called the
authoritarian moment and it's on sale
right now and there couldn't be a more a
more appropriate time for it more
necessary book for this time than the
authoritarian moment because we know we
are experiencing
the less totalitarianism and it's only
getting worse it's not getting better so
if you want to learn
not only about what's happening right
now but the history of it and then most
importantly what we can do about it you
got to pick up ben's new book the
authoritarian moment on sale now at
amazon barnes noble or any other major
bookseller
all right you know one of the uh
one of the one of the things with being
a parent of young children is
it is important to take their feelings
seriously to an extent
right i mean you're not going to affirm
everything they say that's another thing
parents need to learn these days
obviously your kid comes along and says
you know
your four-year-old boy comes along and
says i'm a girl you don't affirm that
but when they're upset about something
you also want to be dismissive so you
try to understand them on their level
and and sympathize you don't want to be
dismissive of of of their feelings
um and so but sometimes that could be a
challenge and so like this morning this
is this really happened
uh i was about to leave this morning and
i heard a blood curdling scream from
upstairs in the boys room and uh i go
run upstairs because it sounds you know
i as a parent you become you become
discerning of the different screams that
you hear from your kids and there's the
uh just the whiny sort of scream that
you'll ignore and not even pay attention
to but then there's the i'm hurt i'm
injured scream and that's what and
that's what gets you into gear and so
this was a i thought was a hurt injured
scream and so i ran upstairs
i thought someone had you know fallen
off of a bed and
hurt broken their arm or something
and i go in and nobody's hurt it's my
four-year-old son he'd let out this
scream of agony because
and i don't pretend to understand this
this is just what he told me
that um he has these paw patrol books
right big paw patrol fan
unfortunately because i hate that show
and he wants to have all of the paw
patrol books in the world he wants all
of them that's that was his state that's
what he said to his older brother his
older brother explained to him well you
know you can't have all of them because
besides they can always print more and
you're not going to be able to get all
of them
so upon learning that he could not have
every paw patrol book he let out this
this enormous scream and that's one of
those moments as a parent where you you
try to
okay that's oh that's what you're upset
about well
you try as best you can to take that
feeling seriously but it's not always
it's not always easy to do
um all right let's go we'll start with
this
from the post-millennial says oliver
darcy who works at cnn has announced on
thursday on his twitter
that three cnn employees have been
summarily dismissed from their jobs for
coming to the office unvaccinated
jeff zucker adds in his uh memo to jeff
did i just say jeff sucker
jeff zucker
freudian slim there adds in his memo to
cnn staff in the past week we have been
made aware of three employees
who are coming to the office
unvaccinated all three have been
terminated
let me be clear we have a zero tolerance
policy on this
um
and uh and that's all we know i think at
this point at least last i checked we
don't actually know
who the employees are
was it was a senior media reporter
um and then someone in tech and anyone
else
now the interesting thing here is that
so they're firing employees who are not
vaccinated
jeffrey tubin
still has a job
so at cnn right now the policy
apparently is i don't know if they have
this in writing or not exactly but i
don't know if you look at the
at you go to hr and you get the the
employee handbook if it's gonna
if it's gonna say this
but uh the policy is that you can
masturbate in front of your co-workers
and that is not a termination worthy
offense
but if you don't get a certain substance
injected into your body
then that is
you can get fired for that that's the
policy over at cnn
meanwhile more covenant news another
republican governor to be ashamed of
larry hogan is
he spoke out yesterday
against the conspiracy theorists who
aren't getting vaccinated because that's
of course you know that's the only
reason why someone wouldn't get
vaccinated is just because they're a
conspiracy theorist
and he said that uh he threatened to
lock down the state again and he said
if i lock down the state it's your fault
you conspiracy theorists
let's listen to that
look i i don't care what
uh misinformation
or conspiracy theories that you have
heard
the plain and simple fact
is that these vaccines are working
if you're still unsure
about the vaccines
uh here is the important fact
for you to consider
nearly every single person
hospitalized or dying with covid19 in
maryland right now
is unvaccinated
those of you
who refuse to get vaccinated at this
point
are willfully and unnecessarily putting
yourself and others at risk of
hospitalization and death
you are the ones
uh threatening the freedoms of all the
rest of us the freedom not to wear masks
to keep our businesses open and to get
our kids back in school
and tragically
it may be only a matter of time
until you do get kobit 19.
that's some nice freedom you have there
be a shame if something happened to it
now to be clear larry hogan
republican governor of maryland
he is the one threatening to shut down
businesses threatening everyone's
freedom that's what he just did there
doesn't matter it
doesn't matter how many people are
unvaccinated
could be 90 of the country unvaccinated
that's not gonna that in and of itself
isn't going to cause a business to shut
down
no no business ever has been shut down
because people didn't get vaccinated
that is a decision that people in power
make in response to that fact
in it
obviously unnecessary decision along
with other adjectives you could use
in response to it
you know all of these and by the way
larry hogan
another just nothing of a republican
and
he he never
you're never going to see
that kind of forcefulness from that guy
on any issue
this is like the first time he's ever
put his foot down about anything
and it's about vaccines
all of these idiots
they still haven't considered because
they're so drunk on their own power
they haven't considered the other option
they so many different strategies have
been attempted to convince people to get
a vaccine
a lot of it is threatening
uh the two primary strategies strategies
of course threatening and blaming
point the finger of blame this is all
your fault you unvaccinated people
while at the same time fear-mongering by
saying even vaccinated people are
getting sick
well if even vaccinated people are
getting sick then how do you know it's
the fault of the unvaccinated that the
sickness is still spreading
but those are the strategies blame and
threaten blame and threaten blame and
threaten
and then sometimes they mix in um
infantal infantilization so we throw a
little bit of that into
kind you know condescending to people
well let's bring a
juvenile out to saying vax that ass up
none of these people have thought of a
fourth option which is
speak to people like adults and with
respect
give them the information that you have
give them all of the data don't hide
anything
be honest be upfront be forthright
and say you know i think you should get
vaccinated uh here's my case
this is a decision that you're going to
make we're not going to force you to
make it
we're not going to force you to inject
any substance into your body
no matter how i feel about that
substance even if i think it's a great
idea but here's the information and i
think this is a choice that that you
should make
in consultation with your doctor and so
on and so forth
how about that for a message you ever
tried that
now is that going to convince every
single unvaccinated person to
get vaccinated no there are some people
who simply are not going to do it
of all the unvaccinated people right now
if we were to break them up into pieces
and i don't know what the percentage is
for each but
uh there's a certain portion who just
are not going to do it no matter what
you say i mean you could threaten to
actually put them in prison and maybe
we'll get to that point um in fact i'm
sure we will get to that point at least
in some states and that still won't
convince them
and then you have other people that are
kind of in between and then you have you
have people who
you know are maybe still aren't
completely against it or could maybe be
convinced
um
but are also a little bit worried about
it
and talking to some of these people i
know they exist because i've talked to
some of them
and
but they also get suspicious
when they hear this kind of language
the threatening and the blaming
not being forthright not being honest
that makes them suspicious
and for good reason in general like when
when when agents of the state are
threatening and blaming there's a reason
it's it's a good reaction to be
skeptical
that's a good instinct to have
so as i said i don't know how large that
percentage is the people that are still
you know could still be convinced
kind of on the on the edge of it a
little bit
but they're the only ones you can reach
and this is not going to do it just
isn't
and if you if you if you do believe that
this is all a conspiracy theory and that
all of the quote unquote anti-vaxxers
uh people who haven't been vaccinated
even though of all the people that
haven't been vaccinated not all of them
are anti-vaxxers
a certain portion
are anti-vaccine in in the sense that
they're
simply against this vaccine period maybe
against all vaccines that's a certain
portion
but a certain portion are you know
don't have any problem with the vaccine
necessarily they just don't think they
need it
but if it was true that all of this is
these are all just conspiracy theorists
you are not helping to quell the
conspiracy theories by doing this
by threatening to take freedoms away
all right let's go here to a gallup poll
just as a quick interesting note though
certainly not surprising at all
gallup
conducted a poll
asking americans how they kind of
identify themselves in terms of
ethnicity and race and what what terms
do they prefer to be
called and so
uh for example
they asked um
uh
black people do you prefer to be called
black or african-american it's kind of
an easy even split 52-44
and four percent had no opinion but then
they asked uh hispanic respondents
what do you prefer hispanic latino or
latinx
or latinx i think is how we're supposed
to pronounce that
at least that's how we pronounce it in
english
that word
l-a-t-i-n-x that cannot be pronounced in
spanish the word just doesn't exist you
can't pronounce it
um
and here's what they found
the question was if you had to choose
which term do you lean toward
hispanic latino or latinx
and 57 has said hispanic
37 said latino 5 said latix
only five percent and even that seems
a little bit high
so i i'm i'm doubting even the five
percent but that's the most they could
get was five percent of hispanic people
actually like this term
which again is consistent with my own
experience talking to people who are
hispanic i i haven't met one who who
refers to themselves that way or wants
to be referred to that way
and you see these kinds of poll results
and
i guess we're supposed to see this as a
victory for
not for conservatism but just for
sanity
for common sense
for a victory for proper grammar and
language
but it's actually not because you see
how this term is so unpopular
and nobody actually uses it
and that's what the polls confirm
nobody wants to use it
it's nonsensical it doesn't even mean
anything
uh and yet we all know the term don't we
we all know it
so this powerful minority of people this
is yet another thing where they've been
able to inject this into the public
consciousness
the fact that they've been able to do
that
with almost no cooperation from the
actual group of people they're trying to
label that only speaks to their power
that's actually
if i were to look at this from the
pessimistic angle as i often do this
this is really a victory for the left
because they can point to that and say
you see nobody even uses this word or
wants to use it and yet you all know the
word we have forced you to know this
word
and it's it actually is being used it
may not it's not being used by normal
people but it's being used by people in
powers being used on government
documents and so forth
so this is yet another thing that we've
just
been able to wedge into
um
public discourse
against everybody's will
but we have we have this is a victory
for us they would they would probably
say
all right next um
speaking of victories for the left now
they say that silence speaks louder than
words well i think that's the case here
the met the medal winners gold silver
bronze for women's weightlifting did a
press conference a couple days ago
and uh i want you to watch this entire
thing because they were pretty talkative
you know they were at a press conference
and they're asked questions and they had
plenty to say
until the questions turned to a certain
subject and then they all kind of
clammed up let's
watch this
this is for emily you went to the united
states earlier this year and you trained
side by side with sarah in utah what was
that experience like uh then and now
when you are competing on the same
olympic stage
um yeah it was fantastic um i was really
honored to be invited out to the states
to train with the guys and especially
siri you know we get on really well and
we're very like-minded people um and it
was just really you know inspiring to
push each other and to get each other
ready for these olympics and you know
i'm absolutely thrilled that i managed
to share a podium with her because she's
uh she's a real sweetheart
there was a historic night here uh with
laurel hubbard competing as the first
openly transgender in a uh
in a uh individual event and i was
wondering you know what you felt about
that and what you felt that took place
in in your sport
no thank you
no thank you don't want to talk about it
nothing to say
of course if they thought it was great
if they thought it was just great to
have a man uh competing against them in
a in in in a women's in the women's
sports then they would they would say so
because that's what the media wants to
hear
so if they loved it then they would say
it's great yeah we should have more men
fantastic
i love it i know i love to see the
destruction of my sport i think it's the
greatest thing ever
that's how they felt they would have
said it
um so it's it's pretty clear no surprise
that they're not in favor
um i i think we can
pretty reasonably assume that
almost every female athlete in the
country at every level feels this way
whether they say it out loud or not
but most of them are not going to say it
out loud
and you know and i can unders i can
understand the silence i can i
understand what
motivates that
because they don't want to get involved
in this issue they don't want to talk
about this
they just want the medals right they
they don't want the story to be about
this and that's what it would turn into
then there's going to be the immense
blowback and everything else and there's
going to be consequences to
their career and and so on and so forth
any any sponsorship i don't know what
kind of sponsorships a female
weightlifter could potentially get but
i'm sure there are some and those are
going to go away if they start speaking
out against this
um so i i get that i really do
but at the same time it's like we talked
about at the top you know people want
solutions
but they want the easy ones they don't
want to make serious sacrifices
and so most of the time when you hear
someone say what's the solution i i only
want to hear solutions
the word they're leaving out is easy
what's the easy solution
when most when in most cases there is
not an easy solution
especially when we're talking about our
culture
fixing problems that are deeply embedded
in the culture there's not an easy
solution
and that's the case here too
that
at a certain point
people need to have some courage
i understand why people don't have
courage
i understand again the instinct to not
want to get involved
and i'm very sympathetic to that
i mean these female athletes they didn't
sign up
for this
the you know
they don't want to get
tossed into the middle of this
drama over this guy who came
i get that
it's like anybody else
you know people working their normal
jobs uh uh encounter a lot of this kind
of thing and they're supposed to just
put up with it they don't want to speak
up because they could lose their job and
you got to you know you need your job
you got to provide for your family all
these things
so i get all of that but but
at a certain point
some courage is required
and if we're not going to have any
courage at all
if we're not willing to make any
sacrifices at all
then there is no hope
okay you may as well i mean flee into
the woods flee into the wilderness go
live in a desert in a cave or something
get out while you can go find a go find
a
deserted island somewhere
don't know
maybe go down to antarctica go somewhere
because there is no hope in this culture
at all
it is nothing but darkness and despair
that lays before us
if
we have ruled out simple courage
and that means just normal people
who don't want to get involved in these
kinds of things are going to have to get
involved and get involved just means
speak up
say i've had enough of this
think about that woman at the the we spa
in los angeles just a normal woman
okay i'm sure she doesn't wake up every
day saying i want to get involved in
trans issues today
but she was in the in the locker room
and she saw a naked man walk in there
you know displaying his penis to all the
women and children and she said no
absolutely not and she just reacted
with some courage
um
that's what women need to do in locker
rooms when the men come in
and when they intrude in sports
that's what men need to do also
you know what about all the men what
about what you know there was a woman
speaking out at
wii spa
what about all the there weren't any
other you know the husbands were not in
the locker room when that guy walked in
but many of the women in that locker
room have husbands
and i'm sure those women came home and
told their husbands what happened
why aren't the husbands beating down the
door
and saying what are you doing subjecting
my wife and my children to this
so some basic courage is needed
to begin with that's like step one
if we're to have any hope in this
culture
of solving any of these problems and
reclaiming it at all then it's going to
require us all to have some courage and
speak up and not be silent
understanding that there are going to be
consequences and we will suffer those
consequences and the consequences might
be severe for us
we might lose money we might lose
you know
we might we might lose standing in our
community we might we might
have our friends and family turn against
us i mean all that might happen it
probably will happen for a lot of us but
we have to be willing to endure that or
there's no hope
all right what else do we got okay let's
go let's lighten the mood a little bit
here this is uh just a lot of fun here's
a story in a vermont newspaper called
seven days and it's written by a guy who
had his first experience with what he
calls an assault rifle
at a which is not a real thing but
that's
the the term that these people use so
he's had a gun ranging his first
experience with one of these things
and uh here's what he says
he says while the pistol was manageable
even comfortable to hold and fire the
rifle was a different beast altogether
everything about it its weight tactical
scope and uh overall lethality was
downright intimidating
the fact that the first magazine refused
to click into place didn't help either
further unnerving me what if i just
broke a 3 500 rifle a fresh magazine
worked just fine though and after
loading it i set the target out to 15
yards
when ready i lined up the target at the
in the crosshairs pulled the stock onto
my shoulder squeezed the trigger and
ba-boom
he actually wrote ba-boom with four
exclamation points it is difficult to
describe the impact physical and
personal of that first shot
it felt like a meteor it struck the
earth in front of me a deep shock wave
coursed through my body the the recoil
rippling through my arms and right and
my shoulder with astounding power
being that close to an explosion of such
magnitude controlled and focused
rattled me
i composed myself and continued to fire
round after concussive round the puffs
of acrid gunpowder spoke smoke carried
down range by a powerful ventilation
system my accuracy gradually improved
until it became easier to hit the target
it was exhilarating
but i never got comfortable firing it
i'm not sure what scared me more the
power of that weapon or the fact that i
could have taken one home that day
uh and here he is just talking about a
rifle that was his experience with a
rifle
no shame
whatsoever for for so many men these
days
you know it's one thing as a man to be
afraid of loud noises and to be fr to be
afraid of a rifle that you're firing
uh i understand if the rifles pointed at
you you're gonna be afraid of it
but you're the one holding it you're
pointing it at a target okay like it's
probably not gonna explode and kill you
um it's one thing to be afraid of that
but
to tell
everyone
to be so open about it then to write an
article
advertising the facts
that's a different beast altogether all
right
um let's see let's move on to reading
the youtube comments
let's see ken says matt's commentary on
the whole corey bush thing is kind of
dumb
what she uh says and did regarding
police and security it's not hypocrisy
she never said she wanted to defund
security or police for herself
or doesn't believe that she has the
right to personal protection therefore
it's not hypocrisy it's hierarchy pretty
important distinction to make also did
matches use the term karen a racist slur
referring to white females developed and
used by the left as a racist insult
against white people so now we have matt
walsh using the left's language to
attack and disparage his own race of
people fantastic things are going great
uh keep up the great job matt
okay well ken
you
um i want to be nice about this and want
to be gentle about it but
you appear to be hallucinating
so you might want to listen to the
commentary before calling it stupid
because i specifically said at the end
when it comes to corey bush that
that the hypocrisy is the point because
it's all about hierarchy it's all about
her statement that she's better than the
rest of us
that was the whole point of the
monologue that's the point it was
leading to
and um as far as using the word karen as
i slur against white females i didn't do
that i think you're hearing things i
said many times on the show i've said
many times i've done whole segments on
how
i consider that a racial slur
and so no i'm not going to use it myself
did i say it was i quoting someone and i
said it i don't know what you're talking
about okay
um
lulu well says no way matt is talking
about chris chan it's stuff like this
that convinces me we're in a simulation
a lot of comments like this i mean
apparently i had no idea who chris chan
was at all
but i'm i'm to understand now based on
the comments that
he's apparently a well-known person in
some corners of the internet
and his his life has been very well
documented
um
in fact i i looked on youtube there's
like a 60 part documentary or something
about this guy i don't know
um
this was my first
experience with chris chan and i i would
have to say i hope to never have another
one
let's see matt another comment says matt
as i roll into the weekend i'm looking
for a good playlist other than poo
sheisty cardi b and bts what are you
rocking in your cd player right now
uh well of course you know
those guys also spot em got em the baby
little baby bad baby sweet baby all the
babies takashi six nine
um and celine dion another one of my
favorites
let's see another comment says matt i
can think of one solitary example of a
democrat saying they regret a law that
they helped pass it was joe biden he
said he regretted the 1994 crime bill
but other than that yeah no they never
admit they were wrong or say they regret
a law they passed or signed on signed on
to
uh yeah you're right about that
so that's one example
um
probably there have been some democrats
i'm sure who have expressed regret in
uh
in in their support of the defense of
marriage act
now because there was a time remember
not all that long ago when almost every
democrat and certainly every mainstream
democrat was opposed to gay marriage
and it will always
it always kind of trip kind of kind of
trips you out to think about how
recently that was going back to 2008
almost every mainstream democrat on the
national stage to include barack obama
was a defender of traditional marriage
and so i'm sure some of them have
expressed some regret about that so once
again it's it's like the the few good
things they do that of course they're
going to regret
and um
finally here's a message on twitter that
i happen to see and want to respond to
it says hey love the show i would love
to hear your take on married couples
having separate finances this seems to
be pretty common nowadays
and i personally think it's ridiculous
let's this kind of
dovetails into what we're going to talk
about the daily cancellation but i will
say this very briefly
uh yeah separate finances
doesn't make any sense to me when you're
married
you're either going to be married or not
if you don't want to
share everything with your spouse
you don't if you don't even want to
share your money with your spouse
then
probably just you shouldn't be getting
married in the first place
nothing good ever comes from that by the
way
when you start separating money and
saying this is my money that's your
money nothing good comes from that in a
marriage
unless we're talking about just okay
we each have a weekly allowance of just
kind of spending cash that we can use to
buy coffee and that kind of thing i mean
that's one thing
but to say here's my account here's your
account nothing good ever comes with
that
you know i've been telling you um
incessantly about the daily wire
backstage vip experience and i've been
telling you for days that it's your last
chance to get signed up
and uh it turns out that today is also
your last chance but this is this is the
last last chance
on monday you might have your last last
last chance i don't know
but don't risk it what you want to do is
go to dailywire.com backstage enter code
backstage for 25 off your membership and
you get automatically entered to win one
of the coolest trips you'll ever take
which is you get to come here all
expenses paid trip and um and you're
going to stay at daily you're going to
visit the daily wire studios take a tour
you're going to meet all of us you're
going to have some whiskey smoke some
cigars it'll be a great time so um this
is your last chance friday august 6th
well there really is this really is
actually your last chance what do you
know so again head to dailywire.com
subscribe with code backstage to get 25
off your membership and a chance to win
the ultimate backstage experience now i
think i really sold that that was a
great read let's move on to this we've
you know we have a lot to celebrate here
at the daily wire including the success
of our newest podcast the morning wire
intent on supplying americans with a
daily dose of nothing but the facts
that's been topping the apple and
spotify charts since its recent release
because it's the only daily news podcast
that values your time and the truth and
uh but you know lots of people are
obviously listening to it we are greedy
we want even more so we are asking you
to make sure you subscribe tell your
friends about it subscribe now to the
morning wire on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts and make
sure to leave that five star review if
you like what you hear let's get now to
our daily cancellation
so today for our daily cancellation
we're going to cancel kate bosworth you
may remember kate bosworth as the
actress who played in that movie almost
famous but you're incorrect that was
kate hudson
then you might say oh yeah wasn't she in
all those underworld movies and again no
you're thinking of kate beckinsale in
that case she's also not the one who was
married to tom cruise for 10 minutes
that was katie holmes
in the early 2000s there was a veritable
explosion of kate's and they were always
starring in the third most popular movie
at the box office at any given time of
all the case of course only kate winslet
remains a popular actress today
recalling the movie that launched kate
winslet's career you might say that she
is
still alive and clinging to the
driftwood while the other cates sink
into the dark icy depths of obscurity
all that to say
kate bosworth is an actress though i
don't remember what movies she starred
in and frankly i've been discussing the
cinematic history of women named kate
for too long now especially because it
has nothing to do with the point so the
point is that um as i am informed by the
headlines
kate bosworth and her husband of eight
years are getting divorced
now this news would be of no interest to
me or to anyone if not for the manner in
which it was announced
now it's common for celebrities these
days and even non-celebrities to get
divorced and then attempt to dress up
their marital failures as something
beautiful
and profound and even romantic
the most infamous example is gwyneth
paltrow who
when announcing her divorce to the guy
from
coldplay
said that they were not getting divorced
but rather embarking on a conscious
uncoupling
now if you're wondering what a conscious
uncoupling is and how it differs from a
typical divorce paltrow's website has an
article written by two new age
fruitcakes with doctor in their names
explaining it it says quote
for our purposes conscious uncoupling is
the ability to understand that every
irritation and argument within a
relationship was a signal to look inside
ourselves and identify a negative
internal object that needed healing if
we can remain conscious of this during
our uncoupling we will understand it's
now we relate to ourselves internally as
we go through an experience that's the
real issue not what's actually happening
from this perspective there are no bad
guys just two people each playing
teacher and student respectively when we
understand that both are actually
partners in each other's spiritual
progress animosity dissolves much
quicker and a new paradigm for conscious
uncoupling emerges replacing the
traditional contentious divorce
well that clears that up but kate
bosworth has upped the ante in a post on
instagram which has been reprinted many
times in the media and has been shared
by people who insist that it is just the
most wonderful and beautiful thing
you'll ever read
bosworth announced the severing of her
marriage vows in a way that is it's
worth quoting i think at some length
worth it for the laughs at any rate
so she writes
the beginning
is often the best part of love fireworks
magnets rebellion the attraction
the onset signals a wide open expanse of
possibility
split a burger with someone when you're
falling in love and you can die happily
knowing that this is your last meal
side note there who the hell splits a
burger
i love my wife but she has to order her
own damn burgers for god's sake okay
anyway
buy a bottle of whiskey and share shots
pour me a waterfall play that perfect
song on the jukebox and dance with
someone you've known your whole life
though you met just minutes ago
inherently we fear an ending
to lose what you've what you have
because you got what you wanted to be
attached to the expectation of the
outcome the great unknown
what if we chose not to fear but instead
to love
if that most delicate and vulnerable
last flicker to the flame became another
type of furnace entirely
perhaps this will sound strange to some
romantic to others to us
this is truth
our hearts are full as we've never been
so enamored and deeply grateful for one
another as we do in this decision to
separate
together over the last 10 years michael
and i have chosen love every time
we hold hands as tightly today as we
entangled fingers on our wedding day our
eyes look more deeply into one another
with more courage now
in the process of letting go we have
come to acknowledge that our love will
never end the connection does not simply
disappear the love deepens the heart
expands we know the 4am calls are coming
songs will be exchanged to communicate
only what songs can do we laugh as we
plan for our next movie together and are
excited to share our latest
collaborations
we believe the most epic love stories
are those which transcend expectation
our greatest honor has been to
experience love like this and to
continue to marvel at the beauty of
love's evolution
what happens
we reach the end of something and
realize
we're just at the beginning
wow
what a tremendous load of
um although i think i i did i i did her
some favors in my performance of that
instagram post i think i think i made it
sound way better than it was
but just to summarize according to kate
bosworth the most epic love story the
truest love story is one where you break
your promises abandon each other and run
off to have sex with other people
instead
that's a that's a love story in the same
way that the texas chainsaw massacre is
a medical drama
you know carving people to pieces is the
opposite of medicine
breaking up your marriage is the
opposite of love
in a marriage love is the choice you
make every day to maintain that bond and
to remain loyal to the person that you
pledged your life to
to sever that bond is to choose not to
love
and that is your choice no matter how
you feel while you're doing it
if you feel warm and fuzzy about someone
while you're in the process of betraying
them
you're still betraying them
you know judas may have still harbored
warm feelings for jesus at some level
when he took the 30 pieces of silver but
he still took the 30 pieces of silver
and by the way betraying your spouse
doesn't become any less traitorous just
because your spouse is consenting to it
i think here's the point that's largely
lost in modern times and it's what leads
to the dissolution of so many marriages
it's also what leads to hilariously smug
pompous and narcissistic divorce
announcements like the one we just read
the point is this
love is an act okay it's not a feeling
love is a thing you do it's not an
emotion you feel
to understand how and why that's the
case just think about another virtue
closely related and one that kate
bosworth also humbly and falsely
attributes to herself courage
okay
is courage an act or a feeling well it's
obviously an act because in fact courage
is the most is the most courageous when
it's performed in spite of feelings
if somebody acts bravely and and doesn't
feel scared when they're doing it
then they're not really being all that
brave because anyone can do something if
they're not afraid to do it that's not
nothing impressive about that
even if it's something even if someone
is doing something that would make you
afraid if you were doing it
it's not really courageous for them if
they're not afraid
what's courageous is when someone acts
bravely while feeling scared
okay that's when courage really becomes
evident
courage is the act of doing something
good or noble or worthwhile in spite of
fear the same goes for love if you act
lovingly towards someone because you
feel enamored with them that's fine i
mean it's nice to feel those feelings
but anyone can do that there's nothing
special about that
real love is to act that way towards
someone no matter how you feel
even when you're angry or upset or tired
or your relationship is strained or
you're feeling resentful or whatever
if you choose to love only when your
feelings align with that choice then all
of your expressions of love towards the
other are really just expressions of
love towards yourself you're choosing to
love when it makes you feel good and
and and uh and then you're making other
choices when those other choices make
you feel good
so you see it's all about you in the end
you're married to yourself
your spouse is just a stand-in for your
own ego
they're kind of like a brick wall and
you're just over there bouncing a tennis
ball off of them the love is a tennis
ball that you bounce off of them only
because you know it comes back to you
there's no sacrifice
you're not giving anything
your relationship is a mercenary
endeavor
i commit to you in exchange for the good
feelings that you give me if those
feelings go away then you're useless and
the arrangement is over
this is how lots of people approach
marriage these days although they may
not be as absurdly pretentious about it
but it's how they approach it
now i'm not saying that feelings don't
matter in a marriage or that you
shouldn't feel warmly about your spouse
or that if you if if they make you feel
bad it's totally okay and you should
simply adore it forever and never try to
change it
um
we are humans after all feelings are
part of the bargain in any human
arrangement and we can never say that
they don't matter
what i'm saying is that love it's is not
itself a feeling
and that feelings cannot serve as the
foundational basis of a marriage
your union has to be rooted in something
deeper and less fickle than that
to be rooted in feelings is to not be
rooted at all
your marriage is then just a light and
flimsy little pathetic thing laying on
the surface waiting for a mild breeze to
blow it away
and that breeze will certainly come
and at that point
your marriage like kate bosworth's will
be cancelled
and today
i have to say unfortunately
so is she
so we'll leave it there for today and
for the week
hope you all have a great weekend we'll
talk to you on monday godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
21.
john vickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our new
show morning wire on today's episode the
political war over cobot escalates
universities roll out new vaccine
mandates and a new bill proposes a
universal basic income for americans
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire